hi there steve kaufman here to talk
about languages and today i'm going to
talk about grammar exercises
but before i do that if you enjoy my
videos please subscribe if you have any
particular requests please let me know
i've seen some people would like me to
do a video in spanish or in japanese and
so forth and so i will do that but today
i'm going to talk about grammar
exercises
french grammar exercises spanish grammar
exercises english grammar exercises
every time you buy a book you know to
learn a language
it's got a lot of grammar exercises
there it seems that anyone producing a
textbook
feels that they have to produce these
exercises to drill you and train you in
whatever grammatical rule they've been
trying to teach because sort of together
with the grammar exercises you have
grammar rules grammar explanations
um i don't do grammar exercises i don't
think that the time and stress involved
in trying to think and trying to get the
right answer and then looking to see if
i got the right answer i've never found
that it helped me very much i found that
the time that i spent just with the
language listening and reading and on
link saving words and phrases and
occasionally reviewing these words and
phrases was more useful
i also found that
reviewing and i've said this before many
examples
of structures in the language is useful
again it's it's a review it's an
exposure to the language and sometimes i
will look at just the answers to these
exercises because there you'll tend to
see
because the exercises tend to focus on a
particular grammatical point you'll see
a number of examples of of correct usage
but exercises per se i don't do
and and what i have found is very
interesting i noticed this as you know
i'm working on my korean and my polish
and then i listen to my ukrainian and
and russian and so forth
those languages that i have studied at
link where i actually have an accurate
statistic on how many words i know
it's not the case for languages that i
learned before link like french or
spanish and so forth but those languages
that i've learned essentially at link
russian czech ukrainian romanian korean
polish
what i find is
that my ability to understand the
language is directly is determined by
the statistic how many words i know
and the statistic of how many words i
know at link
is really
a reflection of how much time i have
spent reading and i always listen to the
same content so reading and listening to
the language so
in fact that statistic how many words i
know
reflects how much time i have spent with
the language
not doing exercises but reading and
listening
and so when i am at a level of let's say
30 000 words known words
at length the way we count them where we
count each form of the word as a
different word i'm still struggling
romanian korean uh even polish whereas
when i'm over the forty thousand fifty
thousand hump ukrainian and czech i
understand them a lot better and of
course russian where i'm over like 80 90
000 words i understand russian unless
there's words in there that i don't know
the occasional word by and large i
understand uh you know 90 of what
they're saying so
all to say that that to me language is
about words
and exposure
spending the time learning words
and grammar exercises i don't think to
me they don't even constitute sort of
time spent with the language time spent
with the languages is listening reading
speaking writing but doing exercises to
me
is is not an effective activity and yet
it's the core of most textbooks and most
classroom activities so i'm sure that
will uh solicit some uh criticism from
uh those of you who are watching but i
thought i would get that out there okay
thanks for listening bye for now